I always remember you drinking milk
because you said you wanted your bones
to get strong and I was like funny I'm
going to have tequila and that's going
to make my bones weaker well I think it
was my first time having wine was while
we were shooting that movie in Paris
that we would like go out there were so
many of us like young people it was like
Natasha Leon and Gabby Hoffman and live
and such Edward Norton goldon
hosc it was just like all of us running
around Paris having fun together I mean
it really was an absolute dream it was
and yet I heard recently that you said
if your kids or a kid wanted to get into
the business what would your reaction be
cuz I know what mine is yeah I feel like
they should wait until they're grown-ups
I totally agree I had a great experience
me
well
I had a lot of different experiences but
I feel like it's lucky that it wasn't
very bad it doesn't have a good track
record no by the way congratulations
your soccer team your all female soccer
team play thank you Angel City Angel
City has been so exciting it feels like
a whole different culture of like women
together going to games together to
watch awesome women play and win and be
incredible athletes now that's something
your children do with you right your son
goes to the games he's invested he's
involved he was the one who inspired it
because I saw him watching the Women's
World Cup and with the same awe and love
for the players that he did with the
men's World Cup and men's soccer teams
in general and I was like that changes
culture like if boys grow up watching
and admiring women athletes the way they
do male athletes like sports is so
Central congratulations thank you so
much thank you thank you Natalie bortman
what can you not do you go to Harvard
you you read books you're you write
scientific research papers you're the
best actress in the world what can you
not do what do you look at and go God I
wish I could do that oh my God so many
things like what uh like playing an
instrument oh yeah like I envy that so
much I think it's so beautiful and um I
mean everything like uh I don't have any
ability to like draw or paint I can't
assemble anything like following
instructions is just like it's very
overwhelming for me are you good at
assembling okay no absolutely not when I
got my first apartment I went to Ikea as
everyone does and got the furniture and
it lived in the boxes like no I can't do
anything no I mean like yeah those
manuals are like manuals my nightmare
manuals are triggering okay good okay
good okay good
[Music]
y